عندما تنتهي رحله كريستيانو رونالدو في
مونديال 2022 ربما لن تتوجه طائرته الى
مانشستر او حتى الى موطنه الاصلي
البرتغالي الدون او صاروخ ماديرا كما
يلقبه عشاقه قد يكون على موعد مع رحله
ومغامره جديده في الملاعب السعوديه وصى
انباء موسى عن عرض السعوديه يدرسه رونالدو
ومديره العرض الاخير وان نذكر بان الانباء
غير مؤكده قد يكون قدمه نادي النصر
السعودي كما تشير الانباء حيث ينتظر ان
يرد عليه رونالدو خلال الايام المقبله بعد
كاس العالم الذي يلعب فيه رونالدو للمره
الاخيره في حياته الرياضيه يرغب رونالدو
في نهائي مسيرته بتحقيق لقب عالميا جديد
مع منتخب البرتغالي يقرر مصيره بعد نهايه
المونديال بعد فسقي عقبه بالتراضي مع
ناديه السابق مانشستر يونايتد ابره
تصريحاته التي هاجم فيها اداره ومدرب
الفريق الانجليزي
[موسيقى]